Olá boa tarde meu nome Dirceu eu queria
começar contando Uma pequena história no
final dos anos 90 um físico Professor
aqui no ensino de física de São Carlos
que iniciou uma pesquisa clínica no
tratamento chamado terapia fotodinâmica
e essa pesquisa Ela acabou se
desdobrando e levou o maior estudo
Clínico do câncer de pele do tipo não
melanoma pelo menos nos últimos dez anos
no Brasil e aí eu pergunto para vocês
como que um físico se tornou uma pessoa
tão relevante numa área que é tão
claramente da Medicina que eu vou tentar
responder essa pergunta bom para isso
vamos voltar um pouquinho no tempo vamos
voltar alguns milhares de anos quando os
seres humanos estavam deixando de ser
criaturas nômades ou seja deixando de
andar por aí e cada hora
e se assentando em pequenos lugares
charminho coletividades mais sedentárias
problema de dar um grupo pequeno de mais
ou menos umas 10 pessoas como se fosse
uma família quando você tem 10 pessoas
você todo mundo que você vai fazer um
pouco de cada coisa imagina que ela é a
comunidade deles todo mundo tem que
saber que é cassar então tem que saber
cara é coletar alimentos todo mundo tem
que saber o que fazer se alguém fica
doente todo mundo tem que saber fazer um
reparo no abrigo ou numa roupa né todo
mundo que saber fazer um pouquinho de
tudo agora eu vou me imaginar que depois
de algumas décadas Talvez um século dois
Aquela pequena comunidade cresceu para
300 indivíduos bom meio de 300
indivíduos Sempre tem alguém fica doente
Sempre tem alguém que vai estar com uma
ferramenta que não tá funcionando vamos
dizer uma lança que quebra que você usa
para caçar sempre tem um reparo para
fazer você não tem alguém conflito então
é natural que algumas pessoas têm uma
habilidades melhores para fazer alguma
coisa
bom então aquela pessoa que parece
sempre saber que remédio usar o que
atitude tomar quando está doente uma
comida de 300 pessoas a gente todo mundo
toda hora tem alguém doente você pega
aquela pessoa em vez de botar lá para
caçar você põe ela para cuidar dessas
pessoas enquanto isso vai ter um outro
que vai fazer um reparo uma roupa ou na
arma enquanto a sua casa forte tá lá na
balança na ponta da lança na França
mesmo né Não tem como então você é uma
pessoa que conserta e preparar mas para
que isso aconteça bom essas habilidades
desenvolveram vão ser no passado de pai
para filho de uma pessoa mais velha por
uma pessoa mais jovem e com isso vai
surgir uma lógica natural de transmissão
desse conhecimento inicialmente por uma
tradição oral né com a escrita e o
registro histórico essa transmissão vai
se tornando cada vez mais eficiente né E
aí você começa a estruturar uma espécie
de um processo de ensino e aprendizagem
para poder passar nessas eleições pra
frente porque com
se você consegue alcançar mais pessoas e
algumas pessoas diferentes ao longo do
tempo bom com esse processo de ensino
vão surgindo especialistas pessoas que
são especializadas em fazer determinadas
tarefas entre os de uma pessoa para para
assumir um papel uma pessoa para
resolver um problema você sabe quem
procurar pô aí a sociedade ela vai se
beneficiando desse processo e enquanto
ela vai se beneficiando ela também acaba
se tornando cada vez mais Dependente
dele e com essa dependência vai surgindo
uma estrutura social né de quem sabe
fazer o quê E essa estrutura acaba se
tornando a ordem natural da organização
social por muito muito tempo de fato até
os dias de hoje
é bom como consequência por meio
pergunta curiosidade e da Necessidade a
gente acaba é aquelas comunidades
acabaram começando a estruturar uma
forma de organizar esse conhecimento e
criar métodos de investigação da
natureza para entender quais eram as
necessidades e ao longo dos principais
dos últimos séculos Isso acabou se
tornando que a gente chama de ciência a
ciência ela cria um participação usar um
método que a gente chama de reducionista
que quer dizer isso ela começou a
reportagem informações e os
conhecimentos e classificar e colocar as
coisas semelhantes juntas para ficar
mais fácil quando eu tenho um problema
Obrigado por determinada coisa e vou
procurar as coisas semelhantes para
resolver esse problema Beleza então é
como se a gente tivesse um imenso
gaveteiro né Cheio de gavetas nessas
gavetas a gente tem um monte de Caxias
nessas caixinhas são separadas
ferramentas Então imagina eu tenho lá
gaveta com pré
e o placar cheia compra é busca uma
caixinha com parafusos eu tenho outro
lugar com caixinhas eu tenho caixa
chaves de fenda em outro lugar martelos
no outro lugar resistores que são José
pois eletrônica e assim por diante Então
você Party organiza a informação de
acordo com coisas semelhantes beleza né
bom esse reducionismo ele facilitou
muito a compreensão e o estudo do
conhecimento que a gente tem enquanto
ser humano né que a gente acabo longo
dos anos então porque simples é se eu
tenho um problema eu preciso de uma
ferramenta eu vou na caixinha lá eu
quero pegar o pneu um parafuso na parede
uma peça eu vou lá pega uma caixinha do
parafuso mas a caixinha de chave de
fenda aperto parafuso calcular se eu
preciso fazer um plano de mecânica eu
vou na parte da física dentro dela eu
pego a parte da mecânica resolvi por de
mecânica se eu tenho um plano de saúde
eu vou na gaveta da biologia pega a
caixinha de saúde e tiro de lá
ferramenta que eu preciso e assim a
gente vai caminhando né eu pego a
E aí que eu preciso bom esse processo
ele acabou gerando uma espécie de um
trem especialização E aí você tá batendo
que a gente acaba falando em português
claro saber cada vez mais de cada vez
menos e com isso quer dizer saber de
maneira cada vez mais específicas sobre
cada coisa cada vez mais detalhadas
então eu sei muito sobre coisas muito
bem definidas essa alta especificidade
acabou gerando um grande repositório de
conhecimento né e parece fazer sentido
porque se eu preciso resolver um
problema eu procuro alguém que entende
especificamente daquilo a lógica parece
fazer sentido para gente né só que
acontece que nos últimos anos que a
gente tem vivido né no período mais
contemporâneo essas especificidades tem
sido necessária de maneira cada vez mais
importante juntas nas fronteiras desses
conhecimentos Ou seja eu tenho que pegar
a especificidade de uma área juntar da
outra e levar os algum limite
a compra outra para poder resolver os
problemas que surgem agora e eu vou dar
um exemplo para vocês o país mais
poderoso econômica e militarmente no
mundo em 2020 realizou as suas eleições
presidenciais né durante uma pandemia E
aí tem como a gente consegue prever os
efeitos econômicos sociais essa decisão
porque a princípio você fala ah é só
eleição de um país que eu não sei o
presidente Só que essa decisão ela vai
afetar a forma como as pessoas se
relacionam porque ela afeta as
fronteiras que ela afeta o direito de
vir ela afeta o curso das coisas ela
afeta o preço da comida dos bens ela
afeta as relações militares ela afeta a
forma como o mundo funciona E aí eu
pergunto para vocês quem é o
profissional que consegue
a entender tudo isso de uma vez que
profissional preparado para lidar com
todas as nuances envolvidas com esse
tipo de decisão
é bom esse processo educacional que foi
a favorecendo essa outra especialização
ele pode concentrar tanto as pessoas nas
áreas especificidade delas que ele acaba
achando difícil a pessoa sair da área
dela e para outra que a pessoa tá todo
mundo centrada naquela área dela que ela
não consegue muitas vezes alcançar Outra
área então se você pensar naquelas
caixinhas que eu comentei nas gavetas
faz sentido associar a chave de fenda
com o parafuso mas também possa ser um
martelo e um nanochip são ferramentas
muito diferentes e fica difícil de
enxergar alguém que intenção de martelo
e fala trabalhar com o nano chip ou
vice-versa como que eu faço isso
e esse processo de formação para o leque
ele foi criado num tempo em que as
coisas eram diferentes está acontecendo
agora ou seja ele criou a gente Ele
prepara a gente para o mundo que não
existe mais e que eu quero dizer com
isso é que esse processo foi criado
antes de as coisas ele foi pensado Antes
que as coisas serem condução então a o
garoto assim nos últimos anos as
mudanças começaram a se tornar cada vez
mais rápidas em especial após as grandes
guerras o avanço tecnológico o efeito da
globalização das telecomunicações EA
forma como as relações econômicas se
estabeleceram por conta dessas coisas
elas acabou exigindo adaptações cada vez
mais dinâmicas todos os dias e a
velocidade essa mudança acabou tornando
o nosso mundo mais fluido o mundo mais
líquido porque porque as coisas mudam
tão rápido que as relações e as
instituições ela se torna mutáveis ela
tava saindo transitórias tudo muda muito
rápido
bom E com isso a propagação de
conhecimento acaba sendo também cada vez
mais rápido se ela é cada vez mais
rápida as respostas que você precisa
para essas coisas também precisam ser
mais rápidas porque se hoje a demanda e
ela logo muda né E esse dinamismo e
acabam deixando o tempo para que as
pessoas possam pegar a área delas
começar a estudar uma outra área e
entender o suficiente daquela área para
responder os problemas essa resposta
rápida se ela não acontece logo a
demanda mudou e aí né Aí se você toma
tudo num passe porque de um lado você
nem a pressão para se adaptar às novas
demandas por outro lado tem a pressão
para chegar no ápice da especialização E
como é que você resolve se não dá tempo
de fazer as duas coisas
E além disso a especialização ela acaba
se tornando obsoleta com avanço
tecnológico e eu falo isso porque que
que eu quero ser obsoleta ela passa não
fazer mais sentido se você pensar no seu
celular você tem um problema tecnologia
para o seu celular hoje talvez aqui três
anos não faz uma diferença você resolver
o problema porque a tecnologia já mudou
todo mundo que entende isso né E aí
enquanto eu tô falando quando eu penso
nessa questão tecnológica tem máquinas
que estão fazendo de maneira mais rápida
e mais eficiente qualquer trabalho que
eu sou capaz de fazer de maneira
específica Principalmente quando eu
penso em robôs Inteligência Artificial
Associados a eles né só que você vá Tudo
bem então as máquinas vão passar por
cima da gente tem uma coisa que as
máquinas não são capazes de fazer tá as
máquinas não são boas e improvisar que
as máquinas não tem criatividade e esse
é um ponto importante a evolução do ser
humano ela favoreceu adaptação nossa né
ao longo dos milhares de anos de
evolução do ser humano a
Eu quero uma forma de cimento nossa
capacidade de adaptação e de correlação
de informações e isso foi muito mais
importante que as nossas habilidades
permite tornar muito especialistas em
algumas coisas bom e o que eu tô falando
disso porque essa capacidade de
correlação de cria e a criatividade
nossa que está relacionada com ela que a
consequência dela ela está no cerne da
solução desses problemas que surgem da
catar outra especialização né essa
capacidade ela vai acabar permitindo que
a gente tenha novos olhares para as
coisas seja olhares experientes para
áreas novas ou olhares revigoradas para
coisas que já foram olhados muitas e
muitas e muitas vezes um exemplo
interessante é a biologia a Biologia no
seu começo ela é muito descritiva mas
com o avanço da química e quando a
química começa a entender melhor a forma
como funciona as moléculas biológicas a
Biologia vai se transformando E hoje é
impossível imaginar biologia sem a
química
e esses novos olhares eles dependem de
profissionais que têm o perfil para
trabalhar nessas fronteiras do
conhecimento né então que seja
participando pegando do seu conhecimento
a sua área de conhecimento e levando ela
para Fronteira seja tendo uma formação
interdisciplinar ou seja com as
disciplinas conversando ao longo da
formação e isso vai servir para fazer
conexões esses perfis eles são a ponte e
o caminho na solução dos problemas que
vem nos nossos dias né então entender a
complexidade do cérebro consegui
resolver as doenças mais complexas A
Engenharia Genética responsável o manejo
Consciente e responsável dos sistemas
econômicos tanto com responsabilidade
social quando consistente
sustentabilidade ambiental Global esses
problemas eles vão resolvidos por as
características e aí Você deve olhar
para mim falando e falar muito bonito
Dirceu mas é
é uma pessoa formada por esses processos
que geram pessoas junto especialistas
pode se tornar interdisciplinar como é
que a pessoa faz isso bom aqueles
finalidade ela Exige uma adaptação
constante da gente então a criatividade
EA curiosidade elas são fundamentais
nesse processo aí você vira para mim e
pergunta de novo mas eu como que eu
posso ser mais criativo Como que eu
posso ser mais curioso Olha uma das
coisas eu te garanto você precisa estar
disposto e você precisar desse posto a
pensar fora da caixa que a gente quer
dizer com isso o olhar as coisas de
outros pontos de vista olhar as coisas
pelos olhos dos outros porque quando
você muda de perspectiva você começa a
ter novas dúvidas com as dúvidas minha
curiosidade e assim você começa a
encontrar respostas para problemas que
você encontre você tem né Além disso tem
uma outra característica que é
fundamental com
a ação é preciso que haja uma linguagem
comum para que as pessoas possam trocar
informação essa linguagem tem que ser
uma coisa adequada que permita que essas
pessoas de áreas diferentes possam
conversar e se entender e não só essas
pessoas que têm esse perfil
interdisciplinar o que atuam de forma
município multidisciplinar mais para que
elas possam comunicar o que elas
encontrem nessa área para as pessoas que
estão longe dessa interface porque as
pessoas vão ter que tirar proveito
daquilo que está sendo gerado nessa
região é prolifera de informação sejam
Tá chegando muita informação ali na
interfase E aí a gente começa a pensar
em colaboração coordenação
compartilhamento faz sentido que você
pensa em linguagem né porque se você
pensar nela como código comum de
comunicação e se associar isso a nossa
capacidade humana de partilhar afecções
ou seja de acreditar em ideias em comum
e de colaborar uns com os outros essa
a nossa associada a linguagem foi que
fez com que a gente dominasse o planeta
né inclusive superando os desafios
evolutivos entre mulas necessidades de
evolução fisiológica porque a gente
consegue com as outras capacidades
cognitivas e essas habilidades resolver
problemas que teriam que levar milhares
de anos e mutações para que
eventualmente o organismo se adaptar se
então gente conta dessa vez de
colaboração coordenação compartilhamento
adaptação parece fazer sentido porque eu
tava falando não é porque o que trouxe
os seres humanos até aqui hoje são essas
características que são comuns a
interdisciplinaridade E são essas
características que vão levar a gente
para resolver os problemas o nosso
futuro é assim que o engenheiro vai
entender as condições biológicas para
manter um organismo vivo no espaço é
assim que um filósofo consegue olhar
para teorias cosmológicas e entender
como é que elas impactam a vida das
pessoas é assim que o matemático olha
é mais humanas e consegue tirar dali
parâmetros que vão ser utilizados em
modelos para prever a economia e é assim
que um físico se torna o ponto chave no
trabalho multicêntrico de pesquisa
processamento do câncer de pele obrigado
a